[Applause]
he just
went hey I'm doing a show how are you
all
right we'll continue this after the show
at my place it's Friday so you know what
that means let's welcome tonight's guest
he loves coming on this show so he can
bathe in the bathroom sink founder ofthe
lopus party.com Michael
lus she just wrote a children's book so
CNN viewers will have something to read
author Ashley
stclair when she was in Africa children
asked her if she had enough to eat New
York Times bestselling author and Fox
News contributor cat
Tu and he flosses with the power line
New York Times bestselling author
comedian inform NWA world champion
tyus
I'm already
tired
wow before we get to some news stories
let's do
this Greg's
leftovers M yeah leftovers where I read
the jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck for every bad one we
will rip a toenail off of Joe Mackey's
feet I know
[Laughter]
11 all right Mike an announced that he's
ending his presidential campaign after
much prayer and reflection marking the
only time his campaign did have a
prayer
a nice guy though according to the White
House President Biden grew worried about
AI after seeing it featured in the new
Mission Impossible movie scaring him
almost as much as when he thought 50
Shades of Gray was about a stool
sample
it's a poop joke VP comla Harris said
she'll research the best way to deal
with AI as soon as someone can help her
spell
it cuz she's
stupid Florida Governor Ronda santis was
accused of trying to look taller due to
the odd shape of his boots the STIs said
to ignore his upturn toes and he's eager
to show America what he can do once he's
done making toys for
Santa tick to influencer claims you
could tell a woman's age by the length
of her socks and the loneliness of a man
by the stiffness of
his
oh come on man I don't even know what it
means I'm not telling you yeah I don't
get that at all no tell him no one by
the way AI has helped create a new
Beatles song featuring the voice of John
lenon and music fans are reminded if you
want to hear more songs from dead Brits
there's a new Rolling Stones album
boy you guys are
sensitive
[Music]
a what do you think this is
outnumbered Robert dairo appeared in
court this week in a discrimination case
filed by his former personal assistant
although testimony was delayed for
several hours when dairo kept asking the
judge are you talking to
me
thanks if found guilty dairo would be
required to pay $12 million and punished
with repeated viewings of Meet the
fuers former CNN anchor Brian stelter
posted Halloween photos dressed as a
Taylor Swift fan the photos delighted
families in his neighborhood who can now
identify the man who ate their
pumpkins never over it's never over he's
going to be on this show soon I promise
a bishop in Poland quit his job after an
all male orgy in a rectory went
wrong I know he apologized saying he
didn't know what came over
him that may be the best joke ever
written according to the National Retail
Federation where I get all my news
Americans were expected to spend a
record-breaking 12.2 billion on
Halloween candy this year and that's
just one guy from
Jersey Kim Kardashian released a bra
with fake nipples to make you always
look cold meanwhile Prince Harry plans
to release an underwear that makes it
look like you have
testicles that gets
Applause I don't understand you
people a tortoise in Florida was found 5
miles from his home after being lost for
3 and A2
years and no one was more relieved to
have him back than his
father the Natural History Museum in NYC
is adding a life-size replica of an Ice
Age woolly mammoth in fact the museum
was so excited they've already released
a photo of
it
[Applause]
and finally oh never thought I'd be
happy to hear those words research shows
that
geners are not interested in movie sex
scenes I guess they'll love the upcoming
Brian killme
biopic I don't want your mercy
Applause to the news Hunter cries boohoo
cuz he loved to smoke booze and screw
this week the B skank settles scores
with critics of drug use and
Hunter Biden wrote an OP ED in USA Today
arguing how he fought to get sober but
political weaponization of his addiction
has hurt more than just him classic
Hunter he wrote the first draft on the
back of a past out Crack whor the man
who put the dick in addiction writes how
his struggles and mistakes have been
quote fodder for a vile and sustained
disinformation campaign against his dad
and an allout annihilation of his
reputation it's funny he thinks he had a
reputation makes no sense that's like
saying all of cat's jokes about my
height made me
shorter damn good one but is it still
disinformation if there's legit photos
of you acting like Caligula with a crack
pipe don't get mad at us you took the
pictures he argues what makes his case
different from other addicts is he's the
son of the president yeah cuz otherwise
he'd be in jail all already sorry Hunter
like my thermometer it goes both ways
sure you're getting all this attention
from Evil conservative media and slapped
with criminal charges cuz you're Joe's
boy but you've also benefit benefited
I'm plowing right through that
yeah for one thing just think how much
money your lifestyle has saved you on
pants but who else with zero experience
gets a cushy post at a Ukraine oil
company and makes millions off his last
name just for showing up with fresh Coke
spackling your nostrils hell I can't
even get an interview for that job and
do we even need to mention China we'd be
here all night and I got better things
to do with my time like helping Michael
Loftus move into a new cardboard
box and now we're all supposed to feel
sorry for him and forget about all the
Shady he's done all these years
allegedly as Hunter might say whenever a
hooker entered a room
that worst supposed to forget he and his
father sold out America time and time
again because he spent the time in
between on hookers and blow sorry Hunter
you can't use a great time as a shield
against flagrant corruption if that were
true then every criminal whose Dad
wasn't president would be able to use
the same defense but they can't because
their dad isn't President so it's not
about you anyway it's about the big guy
and how he used you to get Oodles of
cash from our country's adversaries you
were The Bag Man and was the big guy so
turn your anger towards him and not us
in fact don't turn toward us at all we
have no idea where that thing has
been you know lus as a homeless junkie
who's hit rock bottom do you think the
media has been unfair to Hunter no no no
well if anything they've been they've
been too Fair they've been too coddling
Hunter has an excuse addiction is what
he has it's like uh like what you were
saying uh an
addiction isn't a get out of jail free
card you you still did some
horrible man and so you have to be held
accountable and it's like I have I have
zero sympathy when part of your uh
addiction is getting hundreds and
thousands of dollars from barisma and
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
communist China so now they can hold it
over the president's head it's like I
have zero sympathy like like maybe if he
wasn't uh in the bees have the hundreds
of thousands of dollars coming in and
the art career I might have a little
sympathy but so far no yeah and for a
junkie who's got his life straight it
didn't seem to appear that way when he
ignored his child right I mean is that
supposed to once you get sober you're
supposed to like change things they did
not change things like I made a list of
all the things I've been wrong am I gon
to apologize no gonna keep doing it no
all right Ashley so he says the media
has really been hard on him isn't he
just talking about this show because
nobody else is actually talking about
Hunter Biden he wrote an entire oped
targeted at this show and perhaps maybe
I don't know who else The Babylon be
yeah I think he's he just needs to drop
the ACT I unironically love Hunter Biden
if he drops the act of pretending to be
a scholar and an artist and he just
Embraces being a degenerate Bachelor
trying to avoid drugs and child support
and he Embraces this maybe starts
YouTube channel I can see it now the
title you will not believe what I found
in the White House what I left in the
white
house but he's but he had everyone
playing layup for him he had the FBI
covering for him the media he is in no
way someone who needs a Sab story I know
a lot of crackheads not one of them
ended up on the board of a Ukrainian
Energy company yeah that's almost that's
almost a credit to him cat do you think
the drug use was a cover for him doing
all these deals it's like no I'm just a
part arer then meanwhile he's just
making millions I just think he had
different opportunities most crackheads
do yeah it is unfair to the other yeah I
like how he he talks in the opad he's
like I was taking as many hits on the
crack pipe as possible like yeah it's
crack people don't people don't do crack
because they're looking to get medium
high yeah that is true there's no like
crack Vineyards where people like taste
different crack from different regions
crack tasting would be amazing like busy
but not too yeah exactly they they take
notes on the different flavor profiles
of the crack like you did crack the way
everyone who does crack does crack uh
but I have got no issue with him doing
crack I don't I really don't care if he
wants to do crack do all the do all the
crack you want that's fine not my
problem uh but yeah it's more the fact
that you know the corruption stuff and
and all that which is I guess more
boring than all the videos of his crack
use and his penis and whatever else but
that to me just sounds like you know you
know that's how he wants to party I
guess go ahead yeah it's not about the
partying Tyrus it's about everything
else so do you okay there's an ulterior
motive to him doing this column now what
is it why is he bringing it up because
he must be getting close to the
financial corruption and he's going oh
it's about the drugs you know it's it's
this is why I don't believe in pictures
and video anymore because the balls on
this guy you would think in every photo
they'd be standing out for all of us to
see like this is this he represents
pretty much the entire extreme left now
they want to do all kinds of fun and
then when somebody brings the
accountability word up how dare you go
after my drug use no one would have gave
a
flying about your drug use if you
weren't using the money you were
stealing from the American people and
influence to buy your crack you were so
cocky with it you're the you no he's not
like other crackheads because the only
reason why was doing crack was because
he's cheap he loved money more than he
loved drugs because he was always
bitching about the big guy taking his
10% that little check we saw that was
$40,000 which is 10% of $400,000 and I
don't have to be on crack to know where
that came from so he doesn't if I was a
crackhead I would be offended that he
would even have the gall to hold a pipe
in front of me like no sir you had the
money to do cocaine but you were too
cheap and you were so cocky and Arrogant
with it he's got the FBI buying his
crack he's got the CIA killing his horse
like he's got it all going together and
he wanted to make a fun video montage of
it and just enjoy himself and he was so
arrogant he literally took his laptop
with him doing everything under the sun
to a regular guy like here fix this
that's beyond arrogant yeah there
probably are better organized crackheads
out there yeah not one person in his
Entourage not one person his Entourage
said hey man we need to take this lapt
top smash it in a million pieces and
swim it down with one of your dead
hookers in the bottom of the ocean like
that never crossed anybody no bro I'm
untouchable matter of fact I'll have the
FBI drop it off themselves you know what
I'm saying like that's he's mad because
now we're saying hey yeah the drugs is
the best part of him I think you know I
want to keep that entire rant so I'm
going to say allegedly dead
hookers allegedly yes yeah but allegedly
allegedly
oh
all right I'm Clinton foundation's found
homes for all of them they very well
churches in
Thailand good
save good save up next live hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else